Space pirates make a surprise but welcome return
to the world of "Star Wars" in the Season 3
premiere of "The Mandalorian." But something
is very different about these dastardly foes.
The premiere of "The Mandalorian" Season 3 kicks
off the next chapter of Din Djarin's story with
a bang as he and Grogu land on the planet of
Concordia to seek audience with the Armorer
and battle a colossal alien monster along the way.
Branded an apostate by the heretical Mandalorian
cult "Children of the Watch," Djarin pleads
with the Armorer for forgiveness and learns
that he must bathe in the "living waters" below
Mandalore to erase his past transgressions.
"This is the way."
From there, Djarin and Grogu set off to
visit some old friends as they prepare
for the desolate wasteland that was once
Mandalore. The duo set off for the Outer
Rim planet of Nevarro to speak with Greef
Karga, the leader of the Bounty Hunter's
Guild and new High Magistrate of Nevarro.
They discover that Karga has transformed
the planet from a criminal hotspot into
a booming hub of trade and industry.
Unfortunately, Djarin's visit is cut short
by the untimely arrival of pirates on Karga's
doorstep who don't seem too thrilled about the new
direction that Nevarro is taking. Karga defeats
the pirate leader, Vane, in a duel. Then Karga
tells Vane to alert Captain Gorian Shard about
Nevarro's latest developments. But who exactly
are these pirates? And who is Gorian Shard?
Fans of "Star Wars: The Clone Wars" will
know that space pirates played a significant
role during the Clone Wars, specifically the
Weequay pirates led by fan-favorite scoundrel
Hondo Ohnaka who bore the title of "Pirate
King" on Florrum and often found himself
at odds with Anakin Skywalker and Obi-Wan
Kenobi. Despite his criminal background,
Ohnaka would eventually become something
of an antihero, forming a tenuous alliance
with the Galactic Republic and later helping the
fugitive Ezra Bridger during "Star Wars: Rebels."
Although several of the pirates accompanying
Vane appear to be Weequay, it's worth mentioning
that Ohnaka's rule as "Pirate King" came to an
end when the Confederacy shattered his base on
Florrum. This is significant now that Gorian Shard
seems to have claimed that title for himself.
Vane later returns in the episode when he and
his cronies track down Din Djarin and battle
him through an asteroid field, eventually
forcing him into the path of the "Pirate
King" Gorian Shard and his immense cruiser.
We get our first look at Shard when he radios
Djarin's ship and tells the bounty hunter to
come quietly. The "Pirate King" appears to be
an entirely new species of alien in the "Star
Wars" universe: a hulking humanoid whose mossy
beard and reptilian face make him look like
an intergalactic counterpart to Swamp Thing.
The fact that Gorian Shard seems to have
taken over from the legendary Hondo Ohnaka
as "Pirate King" is extremely telling of
his status among the pirates, though even
more interesting is that his crew seems to be
made up of a swarm of different alien species,
not just Weequay. The way Djarin and the pirates
speak about Shard implies that he's become a
significant power in the galactic underworld,
perhaps even surpassing the strength of Ohnaka.
It's also abundantly clear that Shard and his
pirates now have their sights set on Djarin.
"Kid. Never trust a pirate."
Though it remains to be seen how the
mysterious character managed to claim
the title of "Pirate King" and how his story
might intertwine with that of Hondo Ohnaka,
the return of these space pirates ought to have
plenty of "Clone Wars" fans wondering if Ohnaka
himself might make a surprise appearance
during Season 3 of "The Mandalorian."